One issue with programming at this higher
level of abstraction is that an operator might
write multiple modules, each of which effects
the same traffic. For example, an operator might
write an application that monitors traffic. Another
one that specifies how routing should take place,
another that involves the specification of firewall
rules And yet another that balances traffic load
across the links in the network. Ultimately,
all of these applications, or modules, must
be combined into a single set of
open flow rules that together achieve the network
operator's overall goal. For this, we need
composition operators, or ways that specify How these
individual modules should be combined or composed
into a single coherent application. Let's now talk
about two different ways to compose policies.